for you josh what is on your mind
thanks jen two questions
uh first after the rome meeting
since the war began has china provided
any military or economic aid to russia
or expressed any specific intentions to
do so
i'm not in a position to confirm or
detail any intelligence from here at
this point in time
okay
moving on to the russia ukraine talks
what does the u.s see that would be a
sign for optimism that some kind of
ceasefire could be reached
in which carrots in which sticks do you
think putin is most
responding to if that's the case sure
sure well as you've heard us say in the
past uh we certainly will continue to
support uh the ukrainian participation
in these talks and conversations as long
as they choose to continue to
participate in them of course and we are
trying to boost them by providing a
range of not just economic and
humanitarian assistance but military
assistance that we believe strengthens
strengthen strengthens excuse me their
position in these talks um our view
continues to be that despite words that
are said in these talks are coming out
of these talks diplomacy requires
engaging in good faith to de-escalate
and what we're really looking for is
evidence of that and we're not seeing
any evidence at this point that
president putin is doing anything to
stop the onslaught or de-escalate but
that is really what we would be looking
for
good thank you jen to follow up on their
own meeting what are the consequences
for china if they do aid russia
well i'm not going to get into specific
consequences i think what we have
conveyed and what was conveyed by our
national security advisor in this
meeting is that should they provide
military or other assistance that of
course violates sanctions or uh or
supports the war effort uh that there
will be uh significant consequences but
in terms of what those specifics look
like we would coordinate with our
partners and allies to make that
determination but jake sullivan
certainly communicated that there would
be consequences yes as we have also said
publicly a number of times
is there anything you can share about
the president's potential meeting
a potential trip to europe in the next
couple weeks who he might be meeting
with and really what the point would be
of uh
going to europe sure well we are of
course closely engaged with our nato
partners and european allies as you've
heard us say a number of times about the
next steps in diplomacy whether that's
providing additional humanitarian or
security assistance or the mechanics for
future conversations but there's not
been any final decision about a trip so
i don't have anything to preview about
what that would look like if you were to
take a trip thanks jeff thanks jen uh
the president said back in february that
the u.s would respond forcefully if
americans were targeted in ukraine uh
fred node was killed over the weekend
one of my colleagues was injured today
we're still waiting to hear if he's okay
so what is that response going to look
like
well let me first say your colleague
benjamin hall i know there's not final
reports yet or we would wait for your
news organization to confirm those but
our thoughts the president's thoughts
our administration thoughts are with him
his family and all of you at fox news as
well
in terms of specific actions i think you
have seen
the president
lead the world and taking
putting in place consequence
consequences putting in place uh
repercussions and steps in response to
the actions of of russia the brutal
actions that have certainly impacted uh
ukrainian people and now have certainly
impacted some americans but in terms of
next steps or what the next consequence
would be i don't have anything to
preview for you at this point in time
but we've seen the president been so far
unwilling to draw a red line on the
kinds of atrocities that we're going to
watch from the sidelines we've seen
maternity wards being bombed
illegal weapons being used pediatric
hospitals being targeted um
president obama drew the red line for
syria at chemical weapons so is there
any thought process about what we're
willing to watch happen well jackie i
think it's important to reiterate as
often as we can that what we're seeing
as horrific what we're seeing is
barbaric and the steps that the
president has taken and led the world in
taking have essentially led the russian
financial system to be on the brink of
collapse
we have provided more military
assistance to the ukrainian military and
the ukrainian government than any other
country in the world and more historic
assistance than any other year to
ukraine in history and we're doing that
so that we can support them in this
difficult moment so i would say that at
this moment in time we have been hardly
on the sidelines we have been leading
this effort around the world to respond
to every step and every escalatory step
that president putin and the russians
are taking their concern that if we
don't draw the line at something like
chemical weapons it'll make it easier
for malign actors to
use them in the future because they'll
just go unpunished well jackie i think
that you heard the president say on
friday that there would be severe
consequences and the world would respond
if they were to use chemical weapons and
what we have been doing
over the course of the last several
weeks if not months is providing as much
information to the global community to
the media and to others about what to
expect and when you have president putin
suggesting and russian russian officials
suggesting that the united states and
ukrainians are the ones who are working
on a chemical weapons program it's clear
that this is a pattern that we have seen
in the past of them trying to set up a
predicate for their own actions
what does that end up looking like if
the world responds because so far we've
heard the president talk a lot about
what the us is not going to do
in terms of you know not wanting to
trigger a
war with a nuclear power
but do we believe that putin is you know
a rational kind of person who you know
would pay attention to something like
that i mean he didn't need provocation
to
invade ukraine uh why wouldn't we think
that he would just create a pretext that
is fabricated for something like that
we do that's why we've talked about it
and i think jackie what's important here
is for any and then i'm just going to
move on to get to more people is that
for any president you have to weigh how
you can leave the world how you can make
very clear that actions are horrific
that they are not acceptable they're not
aligned with global norms while also
thinking about our own national security
interests and starting world war iii is
certainly not in our national security
interests putting u.s troops on the
ground in ukraine to fight a war with
russia is not in our national security
interest go ahead
i just have to move on because i
otherwise i'm not going to get to enough
people go ahead
about misinformation in twitter yeah
because
last year the president worked with
twitter specifically to address
misinformation on vaccines called a
wartime effort
has there been any conversations with
twitter to address misinformation as it
pertains to chemical attacks and that
kind of thing uh given that the
you know russia has banned this platform
within the country and they're using it
to obviously target
eyes outside of the country including
within the us to spread propaganda we're
the ones who told you all about that uh
i agree i don't have anything to read
out for you in terms of private
conversations with twitter or any other
social platform but i'm happy to check
and see if there's more go ahead back on
the rome talks uh have you seen any or
did you your colleagues see in this
meeting any sign that china got the
message that they are going to heed your
warnings
well what we're going to be watching
closely of course is actions uh so
beyond that i think as my colleagues
just uh just read out for you in a call
that we delayed the briefing slightly to
make sure you could all participate in
it was an intense seven-hour session
reflecting the gravity of the moment and
it was an opportunity to be very clear
about what you've heard our national
security advisor convey publicly but
more directly about uh what the
consequences would be and your
colleagues have said
that your deep concerns were conveyed
about what would happen if china were to
align more closely with russia just big
picture if china
does not need the us's warnings if they
do move forward with this how concerned
you that this is inching closer to the
world war the president has been warned
of well i think what we're looking at
here
one is if
china were to decide to be an economic
provider or to take additional steps
there to russia they only make up 15
percent or 20 15 to 20 percent of the
world's economy the g7 countries make up
more than 50 percent so there are a
range of tools at our disposal in
coordination with our european partners
should we need to use them but again uh
we are uh don't have anything to update
you on in terms of an assessment this is
obviously an area we're watching closely
well this meeting has been planned for
some time as a follow-up from the
november call the pres the president had
with president xi uh it was a timely uh
an important moment uh to have this
conversation especially given uh the
reports we've seen and uh and the um and
the uh invasion of course of ukraine oh
go ahead one more one
about chemical weapons um the president
as you noted said on friday that russia
would pay a severe price
what would that price look like are we
talking in the realm of more sanctions
can you give us sort of any big picture
about what that would entail that would
be a conversation that we would have
with our
partners around the world but there's no
question if russia were to decide to use
uh chemical weapons there would be a
severe reaction from the global
community go ahead um so when you talk
about kind of the possibilities for
china if they don't go along with what
you've asked um
would you say like you said with russia
that everything is on the table
including ending trade negotiations
sanctions is that all on the table i'm
just not going to be in a position to
detail it further from here uh we'll see
we'll keep having this conversation over
the coming days but you won't do nothing
if china decides to provide military
we've been clear there would be
consequences
yes okay and then what's kind of your
and thinking about what an endgame looks
like as far as um these conversations
with china do you want them to shift
their strategic priorities and not have
a relationship with russia that it does
now or are you looking for something
more modest it's less about changing
their mind and more about making clear
with them what the consequences would be
should they take additional actions to
support uh this invasion
go ahead and the additional 200 million
dollars in securities yes the president
signed off on this past weekend an
official said that part of it would go
to anti-armor and anti-aircraft
uh systems and the pentagon says it's
still kind of in process right now are
these are we talking about weapon
systems that have already been delivered
or is there consideration of new types
of weapon systems uh in this tranche of
funding it's a good question phil my
understanding and just to give you all
uh more detail uh this weekend as i
think you all saw we announced and i
think that's why you're asking the
president authorized an additional 200
million dollars of security assistance
which utilizes the maximum amount of
funding available to provide ukrainians
with the type of weapons they are using
so effectively it's really a continuity
as i understand it let me double check
this for you of the type of weapons that
they have been using very effectively on
the ground to push back
on russia both in the air and on the
ground
so that includes as you as you noted
anti-armor anti-tank and air defense
capabilities and ammunition of other
types and other types of assistance to
address the armored airborne and other
threats that they are facing but my
understanding feels it's a continuation
of the types of security assistance that
that we have been providing and of
course the president uh is looking
forward to there's there's a significant
amount of funding as i think you all
have noted in the omnibus uh for ukraine
which would enable us to provide even
additional assistance uh to add to that
package and then just a quick call to
one of josh's questions deputy secretary
of state uh this weekend said quote
she's seeing some signs of willingness
to have real serious negotiations like
the different a little bit from what
we've heard from officials about the
russian posture up to this point can you
elaborate on what the signs may have
been that may have been seen
uh in terms of giving the deputy
secretary of state that view of things
well she also said that they would have
to back any words with actions
essentially which i think is an
important context right uh they did have
talks today there have been reports that
they will have additional talks uh we've
been very appreciative of the efforts of
our allies france germany israel and
turkey
and others to
be participants in these talks at times
or engage in these talks at times but
again diplomacy requires both sides
engaging in good faith and to
de-escalate and uh what we're really
looking for is a specific delivery of
actions i think it's important to
remember that there have been five or
six attempts to implement a humanitarian
corridor those have not been effective
those have not worked you've seen
through video footage and others reports
that those um that has not been uh
abided by so that is where we are
keeping our eye and focus go ahead kelly
do you get a sense that uh as this
conflict with russia and ukraine is
happening that other actors that are
adversaries the united states china uh
iran north korea are also testing the
west uh with china's
work with russia as you're
dealing with that perhaps with taiwan uh
iran with its rockets north korea also
uh showing its
provocative nature is there a test of
the west coming from some of the
adversaries of the united states we have
not assessed those to be related as you
have said i mean if you look at uh the
iran the missile strike that we saw over
the weekend um no u.s facilities were
hit no
personnel were harmed we were not the
targets of that we have obviously seen
tests and information we put out
publicly as it relates to north korea
we've seen dozens of tests over the
course of past administrations as well
so
i would say we are not assessing it
through those that prism has the
administration reached out to american
companies that have
uh property infrastructure in russia to
expect that to be nationalized by russia
and to lose those assets in russia we
have been uh of course engaged with u.s
companies not encouraging them
publicly applauding them but they're
going to make their own decisions as
private sector companies we've also
conveyed as we did publicly i think on
friday that uh there would be uh we
would certainly look to consequences
should that happen
go ahead i think the former white house
covid advisor andy slavitt has a twitter
threat today in which he talks about the
potential for an increase in cova cases
this spring he says based on european
case increases the us could see a new
rise in code cases uh are you confident
the administration has the real-time
data it needs to provide the best
information possible to the public
to pro to assess data
yes we are i would note that i i did not
see his tread it's his thread but let me
know and i'm not sure if it was related
to the ba2
variant was it related to the ba2
variant okay um what we do know about
the ba2 variant which i think is
important context for people is that
it's circulated in the united states for
some time we've been watching it closely
of course
we currently have about 35 000 cases in
this country we expect some fluctuation
especially at this relatively low level
and certainly that to increase um i
would also note that while ba2 is more
transmissive is a more transmissible
version of omicron the tools we have
including mrna vaccines therapeutics and
tests are all effective tools against
the virus and we know because it's been
in the country and so as we're watching
and i think a lot of the reporting has
been
about of course the uk but also china
and china has a zero tolerance policy as
you all know but they also did not
conduct their vaccination booster
campaigns with mrna vaccines so that is
important context too as you're seeing
the impact what i would note just to go
back to your earlier part of your
question is that we are still pressing
the place where it is concerning is the
fact that we need additional covet
funding um and we have talked about this
we talked about this a little bit in the
past but last week i was running
together but um but without covid
response resources and additional money
there could be immediate impacts on
testing capacity the uninsured fund
which offers coverage of testing and
treatments for tens of millions of
americans who lack health insurance and
an on our supply of monoclonal
antibodies and that means that some
programs if we don't get funding could
abruptly end or need to be paired back
and that could impact uh how we are able
to respond to any variant of course
one more question we noticed the
president when he came on stage today at
the marriott had a mask on is that
something he's been advised to do or is
that something he just feels more
comfortable it often he does that when
it's required by a specific event as he
did when he went to texas last week i
can certainly check on that he was
tested yesterday and tested negative uh
go ahead um thanks jen uh so on ukraine
the president has made clear that he
sort of has a red line with russia in
terms of not wanting to do anything that
would get into a direct confrontation or
lead to world war three as he puts it
i'm curious and you're not sure in
specifics but in broadstroke does he
have a similar red line um now with
china assisting russia is that does he
not want to get into a direct
confrontation with china and are there
certain things he's not willing to do
because of that
let me see if i can answer your question
but tell me if i'm not um we don't like
red lines around here so i'm not going
to use that phrasing but
um you are obviously correct that what
he has he's been very clear and
consistent about his that he does not
have the intention of sending us troops
to ukraine uh that has not changed i
would look at well we are certainly
watching closely uh the actions of china
whether uh whether that is support of
any kind uh in support of any kind for
russia and certainly there would be
consequences to that
i do think we look at it through a
slightly different prism i mean russia
is invading ukraine uh actively so i'm
not but i'm not sure if i'm answering
your question or not
sort of just to follow up i mean
right no ground troops in ukraine but
also there have been other things such
as not enforcing a no-fly zone or not
providing um the fighter jets that the
president has been reluctant to do
so again you said you're not sure in
specifics you said
jake sullivan said significant
consequences for the chinese but i'm
wondering
if there are certain things that you
will not consider because it could lead
to a direct confrontation with china
that you're reluctant to get into the
same way you are with russia i just
think we look at it slightly differently
i mean what i'm talking what we why the
president has been so clear about not
sending us troops is obviously because
that would be a military conflict um
we're not fighting obviously in a
there's no military conflict at this
moment with china nor do we nor are we
predicting that um so i i think we just
it's slightly different
topic um how high uh is the
administration expecting gas prices to
go um and and how much is there a limit
not a red line but a limited what you
think the the u.s public convention
flows off the tongue it's okay um
so it's a good question we don't have i
don't have a prediction from here in
terms of what it could look like there
are outside predictors of course and
obviously what we're trying to do is
mitigate the impact um you know and
you've seen of course um you know the
the price of oil go down a little bit um
and the president will continue to look
at a range of steps that he can take
whether it is engaging uh through his
team or through even himself personally
with a big global
producers uh or it is looking at a range
of domestic options um but we've seen it
go up i mean we look at a lot of the
same data you look at aaa and other data
that it shows us how much it has gone up
since the period of time when russian
troops lined up on the border but in
terms of how far
you know we still believe it will
continue to go up but we're trying to
take steps we can take to mitigate that
and reduce it go ahead thank you um
i understand you don't want to lay out
what the severe consequences would be
uh if russia used chemical weapons but i
guess what i'm confused about is we know
there's not going to be any us troops no
jets no no fly zone other than the
things you've already done
which you have already described as
severe could you give us some examples
of what more you can do
since you've ruled out all these things
just when you talk about severe
consequences what does that mean given
that we know what it doesn't mean sure i
understand your question i'm just not
going to outline that from here those
are conversations that will happen
continue to happen with our national
security team and with our partners and
allies around the world
you're asking us to believe that there
are severe consequences that you haven't
used yet but that are not on the no list
correct okay but you won't tell us what
kinds of things those might be
we're going to have those conversations
privately through our national security
team and with our partners around the
world okay but but
do you i guess what i'm wondering what
about the argument that there just
aren't any more
severe consequences for you to use
because most of the severe ones you've
ruled out that's inaccurate
go ahead
just on the fed nomination yes
does the white house have any assurances
from any republican senators that they
would support sarah blume raskin's
and did senator manchin give the
president or anyone in the
administration a heads up about his
opposition to her not
to her nomination i i'm trying to figure
out if that was a surprise sure i
understand your question uh we were
aware of his position in advance of his
of senator manchin's announcement
we are
she is one of the most qualified
individuals to ever be nominated to this
position and so where we are now is our
focus on continuing to work with
chairman
chairman brown to garner bipartisan
support but i don't have anything to
read out for you on that front at this
point how did senator mention make you
aware that at this opposition was there
a call to someone in the white house
president no what did that look like and
exactly detail more specifics okay and
just one last question if you don't mind
how is the administration preparing to
respond to the potential supplies for
change shock excuse me posed by china's
decision to lock down the tech
production hub in
shenzhen
so we are of course monitoring this
incredibly closely um and our team is
quite focused on it what i will say is
that because of the steps we've taken
and a number of um
steps we've taken to better uh better
prepare and strengthen the supply chain
um you know we we feel that uh that has
helped us uh will help us sustain um but
in terms of where right now we're
basically in the stage where we're
monitoring with the state department
what we're looking at is of course as
you know the the impact on some of these
ports um around where the impacted areas
of china um and we know here that of
course our port action plan and the work
of our supply chain disruptions task
force uh that we have a strong inventory
that we can rely on it's about 90
percent of goods at groceries and drug
stores are in stock currently and we've
also reduced the number of import
containers sitting at the docks for over
nine days by over 60 percent but in
terms of specific impacts of reports in
china we're monitoring it we don't have
a new assessment at this in addition
up-to-date assessment i should say at
this point in time go ahead thanks john
um is it the us assessment just to be
clear that russia is deliberately
targeting civilians in ukraine
well this is part of our assessment and
reviews we're looking at how we're
whether we will designate as a war crime
and we look at this through
a legal process internally obviously the
targeting of civilians and we have seen
a range of very concerning video reports
other uh would be categorized in that uh
through that as in that phrasing uh but
we have a process that we're still
working through here
last week at a briefing you told us that
reporters should quote not focus a lot
of our conversations about the future of
the united states importing oil at this
point from venezuela
were you were you ruling out that the us
would import oil
i'm saying it's not an active
conversation at this time
all right thanks um does the white house
have any reaction to jenny thomas
acknowledging that she attended the
january 6 rally
i do not
and just kind of on that does her
attendance there raise any kind of
concerns about the independence of the
supreme court potential conflicts of
interest anything like that i just don't
have any more comment on it at this
point in time go ahead hi jen for the
second time in two weeks a group of
hundreds of haitian migrants has
landed by boat in the florida keys uh
given the surge we saw last year in del
rio of haitian migration what is the
administration's reaction to these
landings are there any plans to send any
assistance either to haiti or florida
i'm sure we can get you an update on the
humanitarian assistance we provide
directly to haiti we are the largest if
not one of the largest providers of
humanitarian assistance in the world
in terms of the individuals arriving
i think in florida as you said i would i
would really point to the department of
homeland security we are still applying
title 42 and so that applies no matter
which country you're coming from
good hi uh yeah the president of
colombia said last week that he had
offered president biden the possibility
of supplying more colombian oil to the
us as an alternative to venezuelan oil
is that an option that the white house
is considering
we are continuing to talk to a range of
producers on the importance of
maintaining global supply and this is
not as you know about just the supply in
the u.s but about ensuring their supply
for the global market and we do
appreciate our partnership with colombia
and president biden uh did discuss a
range of issues like economic recovery
energy security during their
conversation uh but beyond that i don't
have an update on what that might look
like
under active consideration
again they had a they had a wide-ranging
conversation a very constructive
conversation uh this is really about
supplying the global markets but i don't
have an update at this point in time
follow-up uh chevron is preparing to
take operating control of its joint
ventures in venezuela reuters just
reported that in case the u.s would
grant them a special license to operate
is that something that's on the table
i think i just answered it a few minutes
ago go ahead
yeah thanks jen uh you said earlier in
the press briefing book nothing has been
decided about president biden uh
traveling to europe can you confirm uh
that such a trip is under consideration
we discuss a range of ways and mechanics
for engaging with our friends and
partners around the world but i don't
have any more specifics for you at this
point
this morning leader schumer and speaker
pelosi announced that zielinski
president silence
will be delivering an address to the
full house and senate on wednesday
morning uh what's the white house
reaction uh to this address are there
any concerns that the white house has
about the ukrainian president
uh speaking directly with with congress
as opposed to the white house on its
various positions and requests we speak
frequently with president zielinski the
president spoke with him had a lengthy
conversation with him directly on friday
and we're in touch with
ukrainian government officials nearly
every day not every day we certainly
support uh leaders in congress inviting
him to address a joint session and i
would again reiterate that their strong
bipartisan support for ukraine for the
leadership and the bravery of president
zielinski and we'll all look forward to
watching his speech on wednesday and
then finally on sarah bloom
and
senator manchin's
announcement that he doesn't support her
confirmation does the white house still
see a path
to getting her confirmed in the evenly
divided senate we are uh going to
continue our work with chairman brown to
garner bipartisan support but again she
is one of the most qualified individuals
ever to be nominated to this position so
that's our focus
that you can get her confirmed that is
where our focus is we wouldn't be
pushing for bipartisan support if she
wasn't still our nominee go ahead um two
questions on uh wnba star brittany
breiner last week you had said you
couldn't comment on the case is there
any update you can give now on the
efforts the administration may be taking
to secure her release we do not have a
privacy act waiver
and does the white house have any reason
to believe that reiner is being used as
a political pawn by the russian
government or does the administration
see this strictly as part of the russian
criminal justice system we just can't
speak anymore to the reports of this
case
go ahead
thank you very much
go ahead
thank you on a possible trip to europe
uh is present by considering visiting
maybe perhaps the ukrainian border and
visit refugees ukraine refugees like our
other foreign leaders are doing is this
something you have to do i just don't
have anything more on the reports
again
we have a range of conversations with
our nato partners and european allies
about the next steps in diplomacy but i
don't have anything to confirm for you
in terms of the report
not just china but some of the biggest
countries in the world like india or
brazil some countries in latin america
like mexico they are not a part of this
economic work warfare
against russia is this something that
undermines
the effort from this white house and
european countries i would say it
doesn't undermine our efforts we've been
working to build a global coalition far
beyond the g7
and our nato partners and had a great
deal of success in that and every
country has to decide where they want to
stand uh where they want to be as we
look and the history books are written
go ahead i think we got to move on who
gets to get around
this economic pressure will stop
vladimir putin
from his invasion well i think as we've
seen the impact of the president's
leadership on the global stage and the
economic consequences that have been put
into place have
led russia and the russian economy to be
on the brink of collapse uh and
there's no question that
over time that will have an impact go
ahead thank you uh furthering that point
um you did mention at the top of this
briefing that there has been no action
on the part of putin to to stop the
onslaught you haven't seen any action
um and that is after again all of these
severe economic
sanctions have been levied and so you
know i'm wondering
why the administration thinks that this
threat of further severe
action
that is vague that is unnamed will deter
him from using chemical weapons
well i think um
the reason that we spoke out last week
about uh chemical weapons is because we
felt that it was important for the
global community to understand that they
had the capacity the capabilities and
that they have used them in the past and
at the same time they were accusing
inaccurately they were spreading false
information about the us and the
ukrainians intentions that was the
origin of why we were so outspoken last
week so uh this is more about us making
clear to the world what we've seen as
patterns uh in the past and what their
capabilities and capacities are go ahead
function um president biden has
repeatedly said no u.s troops inside
ukraine um are there any us troops still
training ukrainians outside ukraine and
if not could that be a thing
as as we move forward you mean in
neighboring
countries outside ukraine and if it
becomes a long-term conflict as
obviously many predict would that be i
think the united states does let me
check with the department of defense we
obviously had trainers on the ground for
a period of time we hadn't then we
pulled them back we obviously have a
significant
military presence in a range of
countries in the region uh but i can see
if there's anything uh that we are
looking ahead to consider an escalatory
type of thing you know a bit like the
mix which got complicated because no one
knew kind of how to get them to the
ukrainians like if you had ukrainian
soldiers going into poland
you were trained by us troops to go back
and fight russia i mean i think really
our focus right now is on providing them
and continuing to expedite the military
assistance to them and the good news is
that we still through our coordination
with them and our nato allies we're able
to get them that assistance on the
ground they are actively fighting now so
that's where our focus really is at this
point in time uh go ahead yeah on the
federal reserve would the administration
then support the four nominees who seem
to have the votes to be uh confirmed to
go forward and deal with the ratsky
nominee after well there's enough
support to move all five nominees
through the committee
so we think the republicans should show
up so that they can vote them through
the committee
one last thing the fact that china is in
the conversation about helping russia um
should u.s companies then look at maybe
decoupling from china with their
investments there and be cautious what's
the message
that you have can you trust the chinese
i don't think it's about trust um but we
have not made an ascor or a request at
this point of that
thank you at the democratic retreat in
philadelphia last week
some of my colleagues were hearing a lot
from democratic lawmakers who want the
president to do more
by executive action whether it's on
immigration or whether it is on
some of the the other priorities of the
administration did he have any
conversations with the members there
about possible further executive actions
and is there anything else
that you're hearing from the members and
those meetings with the black caucus and
other
members of congress in the last week or
two that may
be coming forward
well i would say all of these members
can speak for themselves on what they're
interested in and what they're
requesting from
the president and from this
administration uh we we have a range of
uh executive authorities uh the
president does i should say has a range
of executive authorities i think there
have been some reports about some that
are under consideration including one on
policing which we have talked about a
bit in the past so sure we still
continue to consider what steps we can
take through executive actions even as
we work with congress to see what we can
move through there as well
there's no
update beyond the legal review
continuing on the student loan question
i don't have an update at this point in
time no go ahead in the back
good thank you
okay and then i'll go to your friend
on north korea it is reported that north
korea the icbm launch is imminent do you
have anything on the north korea's
imminent launch in seoul
i i don't have anything on that uh
report i've not seen that report what i
can tell you is that um you know as you
know last week we uh proactively decided
to reveal information publicly about uh
recent tests and share it with allies
and partners as well as congress uh we
have seen north korea escalate its
testing in different periods over the
last four presidents and this time north
korea hid these tests unlike the fanfare
over past tests but i don't have
anything to predict in terms of the
future i said i'd go to go ahead
japan and some of the other treaty
countries are increasingly alarmed after
afghanistan and this recent situation
could you let the japanese
government know that the security treaty
will be honored and then second for
those of us that were invented during
the war the whole situation with
afghanistan is quite personal there's a
large number of our people that helped
us that are still left can you just
update us on on almost six months
whether they'll be able to come back
well i would say on the second part um
that that is one of the reasons that
we've worked so closely with our cuttery
with the cutteries to maintain a
diplomatic presence there so that we
continue to engage with neighboring
countries to bring people home and help
some of our partners and allies who
stood by our side fought by our side
over the course of the 20-year war
that's ongoing in terms of the the
numbers i would point you to the state
department who would have the most
up-to-date numbers i'm not sure i
understand your first question just a
reassurance to japan and a lot of the
countries that have treaties with us
that are worried you know if a situation
like this develops if those trees are
going to be honored which situation how
would it relate to japan
afghanistan
along partners of ours and so you know
the whole situation that's happening now
taiwan there's a great concern that if
you have a treaty and it comes to a
difficult situation whether it's really
going to be honored we've never stepped
back from the commitments we've made
under the taiwan relations act and
the president stands by those go ahead
james thank you very much jen uh two
questions on russia ukraine
prior to february 24 the president
uh our nato allies and the eu were
embarked on a deterrence project
that's exactly the word that you and
other senior u.s officials used at the
time
quite clearly the invasion was launched
on the 24th of february and so
we can say as a factual matter that that
deterrence project failed is it the view
of the white house
that mr putin could not be deterred by
any set of steps or are you willing to
concede that
perhaps some other set of steps by the
president and our allies might have
deterred the invasion uh you know james
i would say that when we put in place
the threat of sanctions and the threat
of consequences
we never thought that that would be fail
proof
or that would be 100 percent effective
we did that because we wanted to lay out
the clear consequences should president
putin proceed in invading ukraine even
as we predicted quite consistently that
that was very much his intention and
what we have done since that point in
time is implement those sanctions and
implement those consequences far beyond
what i think and most people's
expectations were in the world about
what those would look like
i don't think it's i don't think i can
look in a rear view mirror any of us can
and predict what would have been
different what we did is we took steps
to rally the world
to stand up to the aggressions of
president putin and we have implemented
them and followed up on what we
committed to since that point in time
one key decision
made by the president early on was to
remove strategic ambiguity from this
equation
never really was mr putin forced to
wonder what consequences he would face
he was told at the outset
he would never face military
intervention by the united states and
nato uh that
the the full range of the punishments he
would face would amount to diplomatic
and economic sanctions
um
i think a lot of people wonder why
um
a greater effort wasn't made to to leave
mr putin in doubt about the consequences
he might face because the president is
the president of the united states of
america and he felt it was important to
be uh clear with the american people
about what his intentions were and what
they were not and his intentions were
not to send uh men and women their sons
and daughters to fight a war in ukraine
against russia
go ahead
thank you on iran okay i'll do bulga go
ahead ladies first thank you okay
iran the iran talk security was stalled
amid some last-minute demands by russia
are the iran talks dead and if not what
now
well right now um the negotiators are
back home in their capitals we'll see
what happens in the days ahead with
diplomacy around the deal
we continue to believe that um you know
obviously a diplomatic path forward is
the best path forward but this is a
natural part of the process it is also
uh standard for the most difficult parts
of the conversation negotiations to be
happening at the end and then just on
ukraine uh south african president
ramaphosa says he's been asked to
mediate between russia and ukraine
would the white house support that
endorse that
in any way assist with that especially
since the african model kind of tends
towards like restorative justice truth
and reconciliation instead of you know
traditional justice i'm happy to check
with our national security team on his
role what i can tell you is that there
have been a half a dozen global leaders
who have been meeting with both the
russians and the ukrainians and engaging
of course directly uh through diplomatic
channels and trying to uh come to a a
diplomatic conclusion here we have been
engaged directly with them on the front
end and back end of those conversations
and encourage them to also make sure
they are
engaging with the ukrainians and not
just the russians but i will check if
there's any specific about this
i'm happy to check specifically but
again there's a range of countries that
are already uh playing this role so uh
go ahead and go ahead with the
copenhagen think about it sure with code
funds falling off the omnibus yeah and
it may take a bit you know congress kind
of uh bankrolled out of itself has
asked changed at all they
come back to you know lawmakers and said
hey
well it's gonna take a while you know we
need more or it's a different place i'm
just curious about that you mean in
terms of asking for less money or
something like that or
you know for more money what is the time
yeah and does the time you change the
needs of the white house
well the the time i mean we're asking
for money to meet exactly the needs that
are going to start to uh to come up soon
in the coming in the coming weeks even
and in supporting a number of the
programs that have been pivotal to
people across this country especially
people who are uninsured people who are
relying on access to free treatments
testing
vaccines obviously these are programs
that it's not only in the united in the
us government's interest to continue but
it's in the interest of the american
people especially people who don't have
the resources to cover and pay for a lot
of these different uh treatments uh we
had originally we had requested a 22.5
billion dollars i think you're aware for
immediate and urgent cobia response
needs because that is the funding we
felt
we needed that does not mean it would
cover uh the needs in forever that would
just be the needs we have at this moment
in time so these conversations are still
ongoing with uh with leaders in congress
uh we we are but we want to be very
clear about the fact that uh some of
these programs could abruptly end and be
paired back uh without additional
funding uh uh just uh you you mentioned
the uninsured for the hearsay program
that reimburses front shirt fund you
guys previously said it would end this
month is that timeline still there in
terms of that you mean if we don't have
funding yeah
a lot of these programs could end quite
abruptly so uh it could uh but i will
check and see if that specific one would
go ahead
um title 42 two related questions one of
them democratic senators on congress
people and activists were criticizing
the president during the campaign he
said that this trump era policy was
inhumane yet he's keeping it even though
the country's opening again but then a
few days back the cdc decided to let
unaccompanied minors in so the fear is
that this is going to
make a lot of parents to send their
children by themselves and lead to
another humanitarian tragedy at the
border
well i would say first um i mean as
you've noted um the cdc makes
determinations about title 42
i think
as it relates to the recent decision i'd
have to talk to the department of
homeland security specifically about
that and how they're applying it or
implementing it as you know our
intention is certainly not to put more
children
in danger uh or put them uh
incentivize parents sending kids on a
journey that's treacherous and dangerous
um across the border uh but the
president
you know he is implementing this because
we are still in the middle of a public
health uh crisis uh that continues to be
the case as designed by the cdc he still
plans to reopen the border and make more
humane policy like he promised that is
that is what he proposed on his first
day in office and we were very
supportive of the efforts in the senate
to do exactly that and just because it's
not done yet it doesn't mean that we
aren't going to stay at the fight to get
exactly that accomplished and done
is there any reason why you've not
condemned racism against africans in
ukraine i understand that ukrainians are
the victims here they have been bombed
by russia and they have been killed but
a lot of africans there are facing
racism i know you are providing a lot of
financial assistance to poland to
ukraine but africans there have been
ba from even entry poland why have you
not officially the white house issued a
statement condemning racism against them
we have and i believe the state
department has but we have spoken
out against that and express concern
about any reports of discrimination or
at the border
finally
i'm trying to understand why you are
trying your end game in ukraine
you are not going there you are not
selling trump there there will be no
flight no no flights on
over ukraine and are you really a fair
assessment to say that you are pushing
these guys to commit suicide knowing
that russia has a superpower and
eventually they will capture the main
cities kiev and kharkiv and all the
cities around there what's the end game
well the end game is really a question
for president putin we have we have
completely crushed his economy
we have provided military assistance
humanitarian assistance to the
ukrainians enabling them to fight back
for far longer uh than the russian
leadership uh anticipated uh and again
he has to uh he has determined what the
path forward looks for like for him
thanks everyone
[Music]
going after journalists i don't have any
details on that for you
thank you thanks
you know
george